but it was good and I think people
really enjoyed it the the viewers ship
was generally higher for this one I mean
I think it's kind of lined up really
well because uh you were able to like
promote it on the streamer yeah I was
about to say yeah congratulations on
winning the best uh philanthropic
philanthropic event yeah philanthropic I
learned that word for the event as well
yeah I mean I yeah I think a lot of
people were surprised me too I think
everyone expected Jack to win I think I
think Jack was being what I said Jack
Sean yeah so so annoying that he has two
names yeah Sean God damn it man why is
Jack such an easy name to say as well
Jake no uh Sean's great Sean's awesome
and I think if Sean promoted it more he
easily would have won I think Sean Sean
was like ah you know I think Connor's
nice guy
I love this one I don't know I you know
but I also wouldn't have been mad if I
would have been obsessed I was in thanks
Miss as well yeah which was the other
other event I was up against I think
because a lot of people were expecting
you know they were people nominated as
well but I think everyone was expecting
thanks Mr Wynn because it was just such
I mean just the pure fact that you're
even nominated is like yeah yeah I was
you nominated for two categories that I
was nominated in variety streamer which
I didn't expect to win either because it
was xqc was in the same category yeah
yeah yeah I mean that's just a different
ballpark of viewership and you know his
his audience watches the stream rewards
and knows it yeah so I yeah I think uh I
I was I mean I was honored to win
anything I thought it was hype that was
the event itself it was fun the stream
rewards was really fun uh there was so
much drama that happened afterwards as
well I heard about that yeah yeah I saw
the the [__] uh the [__] kid
that's everywhere came up to me you know
the kid who's in the Bill Clinton he's a
Bill Clinton he was there yeah he
crashed it of course he did but he
didn't get in he was outside yeah so
after the event ended
um we went outside and I was waiting for
my Uber
to go to the the after party because
it's always an after party everything we
were waiting there the Bill Clinton kid
comes up to me
um but he's dressed as Boba Fett right
if you don't know who the Bill Clinton
kid is he's this guy who just who just
like video bombs stars and events he's a
very weird kid yeah the first time I'd
heard about him was at the game awards
the [__] Elden ring Japanese team
yeah and he starts going on about Bill
Clinton Orthodox reformed Rabbi or
something it was such a random it was
very bizarre
I don't know why he's turning up to all
these Awards ceremonies he's kind of
he's a meme because he's everywhere yeah
it's like spotting the yeti yeah yeah
and so he he came up and he he was in
this Boba Fett costume in his face he
was all covered up and he started
talking and I immediately could suss out
who it was from The Voice right and I
was like oh yeah the Bill Clinton kid he
shoved his camera in my face and was
like where's Hassan where's Hassan all
right and I was like what he's like
literally here with the flash on and I
was like Paparazzi yeah and I just was
like get closer get closer and I put my
face in his phone because I was just
like I was like what the [__] this kid
one and I was like yeah he'll come out
he'll come out and then he'd finally I
think he got bored because I wasn't like
pissed off yeah I was like oh cool cool
yeah put the phone in my face that's
fine
um and then yeah he then he left and
then kept harassing everyone else
bro like streamers have got Paparazzi
now no no not Paparazzi she's just him
just him just him he is the paparazzi of
Twitter it's fun though I mean it was a
good like uh I I got to meet a lot of
other streamers I didn't know I was
surprised a lot of them knew of me I was
like come on thanks man well I mean like
the street yeah the streamer Community
is pretty small yeah but I don't I don't
really once you're in you're in I feel
like I don't really collab with a lot of
the LA crowd I'm just gonna do my thing
yeah but a lot of them like know of you
it definitely helps your light homies
with Ludwig yeah I mean it's it's like
you know the YouTube scene back in 2012
or something yeah I'm sure all of the
top YouTubers knew of all of the other
top YouTubers now and now like there
could be a guy with 10 million
subscribers that I literally have never
heard of in my life you know have you
ever like gone to a like a fresh YouTube
account and just like seen the
recommendations it's so weird to see so
many videos with like 100 million views
200 million views and some some
different Youtubers with like tens of
millions of subscribers it's like a
global platform yeah and you just like
never heard of them ever you know sure I
think it's just yeah it's just because
it's different hours and amount of
content that is consumed and by how much
right yeah yeah so I think that's why
but no it was a good event overall and I
enjoyed it there was um they brought out
like macaroni and cheese and chicken
nuggets for the dinner
um that's a stream of diet right of
course that is yeah that's like gamer
died if I've ever heard one in my life
yeah
yeah it was um it was kind of over
pretty quickly but it was very fun and
uh I went pretty much just for that and
then I yeah
yeah the after party was fun and then it
got ended really early because another
content creator got too drunk and yeah
ambulances and stuff I don't know what
happened all I know is that I was
chilling and I try to stop the person uh
from going in the pool yeah and then I
was like all right go off I think I left
actually and then um next thing I knew
the security was like get out no one's
allowed in and I was like what damn I
was eating the burgers there's free
burgers how long did the party go on for
three hours okay it was like from I want
to say like nine ten no not even that it
was like two hours to like before
midnight and then right yeah and then it
kind of all just fizzled out
um yeah it was weird
it was it was weird hearing things
through the grapevine you know yeah
because yeah we ended up in like this
weird like everyone was like okay
everyone's like go here now because like
when the when the main party like if you
ever had this experience we've gone to a
party yeah um this is like a very
um like when there's too many people and
there's a venue yeah like and then the
venue say like they shot a tan or they
shouldn't laugh it's like where do we go
next and then everyone everyone kind of
scatters and tries to like hear where
you going where are you going so we went
ended up going to this like club and we
just couldn't get in because it was full
and we were just standing outside for
like 10 minutes like what the [__] are
we doing I was like this sucks let's
just go let's just leave and then so I
was like no no wait there's this other
place and apparently there's
he's gonna blow your mind I've never
heard of this
there was this house there was a credit
card and the allow the amount of credit
you're allowed to have was based on how
much social media following you had
what that is the most La thing I've
heard in my life yeah it was called uh I
guess called carrot with a K as carrot
credit
as if people aren't clout Chasers enough
man now there's like a monetary value
that you can give with a credit card
it's like don't worry boys I'm paying
with Cloud yeah right now this is uh
yeah you're literally playing with Cloud
credit yeah
a new credit card for tick tockers
YouTubers instagramers who can't get one
from the bank so
what I think it is is like they just
give probably like outrageous uh what's
the uh what's the word apis is that what
it is uh apis aprs yes credit apis they
probably just give I think they just
give outrageous credit uh like like if
you miss it you get absolutely [__] by
that yeah yeah uh and they hand them out
and it was like a house it was like
their house and I don't know like how
this all came about because like it was
just a house like a mansion and it was
it had branding of this thing everywhere
and we all just showed up and there was
white Claws and I I don't think they
knew I don't think that was the plan is
really weird I showed up and it was just
bizarre wait so hold on I'm confused as
to how this like credit system works so
it's like
we're interested in that so it's like
you say so it's based on how many social
media followers you have yeah yeah and
so it's like is is there like a
conversion rate of like yeah one dollar
is one cent or like well but like but
like is there like a tick tock currency
versus a YouTube currency versus because
like tick tock tick tock followers it's
not the same as YouTube subscribers you
know like an exchange
yeah this is from someone called whey
this is like their experience with it
yeah while Wade wasn't able to share the
specific criteria for approval he says
that there are General follower accounts
that carrot looks at for applicants
YouTubers who generally have at least a
hundred thousand followers instagrammers
should have at least 125 followers and
two talkers should have have a whopping
2.5 million followers okay wait
estimates that the average card holder
has an annual income of more than five
hundred thousand dollars so Tick Tock is
one like the Vietnamese Dong of
the digit is
for the Venezuelan dollars
and I I think yes so I think they just
analyzed how much money like I think
YouTube they should look at your ad rev
and they're just like okay you can have
this much yeah wow so I think it's uh
really stupid idea um yeah so and
probably something Silicon Valley
dreamed up and is absolutely [__]
stupid idea but they had a house and I
think everyone went that afterwards and
it was much smaller and so a bunch of
people were there and like I I drank a
white claw and I was like dude
I was like I'm done I was like I wanna I
just want to go to sleep well you didn't
sign up for the card no no one had to oh
it was literally just you turn up and it
was just that Brand's house oh why they
had a house I don't know it's not like a
physical card no but it's a physical
card all right but like this house this
house this house is like the the house
for influences or parties or something
yeah so it turned off and it was this
thing and it was the most shittiest
thing ever it was just a mansion for
this thing it just felt like a what a
waste of money for this company yeah
well I guess I know about it and we're
talking about it so maybe they've got
their money's worth on that one party
um but what a [__] stupid idea for a
business
um can we get like a mortgage out with
that like how can I apply for like a
mortgage can I have a client mortgage
the interest rate's pretty insane yeah
yeah yeah
I need you to increase your CPM by at
least a Dollar by the next month have
you ever been canceled please
you know like the customs declaration
form where you like declare like are you
bringing in Firearms narcotics it's just
like in 10 years though there's just
gonna be have you ever been counting
I'm sorry we're gonna have to deny your
Visa
how many cancellation attempts has been
made in the past year please write down
our number
use the lower use the lower prick racket
to explain in more detail
it's like where are we going right now
oh my God holy [__] but yeah it was so
weird a lot of fun yeah it was it was so
weird because you know obviously only
you went and just obviously like the
drama happened and like seeing you
mentioned uh like because I can't
imagine what is what it is like to be at
the center of streamer drama because
it's kind of like I wasn't really
involved I I just happened to stop the
person from jumping in the pool one time
right yeah and just like hearing your
name as part of this you know gossip
that was like being being thrown around
it's like seeing your friend's name in
TMZ it's like what are you doing
just like what's going on what did he do
and it was just like it was like so much
a game of like Chinese Whispers where I
was like some people were just like oh
come on people were people were like uh
assuming it was a different Conor and
people were like saying different things
to what actually happened yeah I was
like whoa hold on yeah yeah they're like
they're like they're trying to throw
Conor in the pool no no I was trying to
stop them from jumping in the pool right
yeah which is different to them trying
to throw me in the pool yeah I think so
at least